ok so I think we'll we do I'd like to
ask can one overarching question then
open it up and take a couple of
questions from the audience and then
really just have each of you respond you
know to those questions as you see fit
yes what I want to do is come back a
little bit to a question that I'd luck
used to sort of frame the final part of
your remarks which was you said it more
eloquently but you know what what would
happen now if what we saw in Rwanda were
to happen again and what I think I want
to use that question for is to really
focus on where we are in terms of our
potential to prevent and I mentioned a
couple quick things that's really useful
that headlock emphasized the first two
pillars of the r2p I think these get
very little attention and the public
imagination but in fact are really
important things that we can do that may
allow us in some situations and ever to
get to the point of thinking about more
drastic kinds of intervention but we
still face the possibility that those
things won't be effective in certain
circumstances and the violence will
begin atrocities will begin and I think
that's the question I really want to ask
what what is our ability now is it
different what what are the prospects
for stopping atrocity once they begin
and what we've talked about a little bit
is the difficulty of getting Security
Council action I think some have
interpreted the r2p doctrine to leave
early some room for other forms of
collective action than security council
authorized action or even unilateral
action and I think we often look back to
Rwanda as the simple way of saying well
if despite the likelihood that France
would have prevented Security Council
action if the United States or some
other country said doesn't matter we're
going to go in anyway and it prevented
large amount of this atrocity would we
look back historically and criticize
that country for having violated
international law probably not we have
the example of Kosovo where the
commission of inquiry said it was
unlawful but legitimate a strange and
troubling legal concept that leaves us
not sure where we are so I guess the
question I have would we still have the
UN Charter saying you know domestic
jurisdiction sovereignty still hold the
Security Council really being the only
alternative what is our potential for
intervening when something happens and
then next that I want to talk a little
bit about zacks focus on retrospective
justice in a way transitional justice to
the extent that relates to prevention I
think it's largely been based on a
theory that through the establishment of
the ICC now I think we'll most people
view that is replacing the need for ad
hoc tribunals although not necessarily
or perhaps through universal
jurisdiction that we have a powerful
force for deterring future atrocity but
again I guess I would like to have us
think a little bit about where we are in
terms of these forms of Justice actually
serving us as means of prevention when
we see prospects of of mass atrocity so
I'd like to keep those questions in mind
and then open it up and I know if you
can see better than i can see i guess i
can see if i cover the light so it's
open it up to questions and then we'll
ask our panelists to go and respond
whatever they would like to yes did the
u.s. have any information leading up to
the genocide and could it have been
prevented in your opinion and could the
scale of the violence have it all been
foreseen a couple more questions and
then we'll turn dark
as you know Rhonda Koppelman and the
Women's Caucus for the International
Criminal Court were very influential in
creating a court that would address
violence against women as this one has
however since then as ambassador Shandra
reminded us last week at a side event at
the csw the Security Council has passed
resolution 13 21 in a series of other
resolutions in terms of the role of
women in the peace process and in
conflict situations yet not one woman
even though the easy council recommended
it from Syria has been part of the peace
negotiations so I am curious as to
whether or not women played a role in
the gotcha which was brought to our
attention by graduate students here at
one point and why you think that happens
in whether that could affect the process
and the outcomes and leave another
legacy David right here and then I think
then will shift to our peril to respond
to these questions yes it was both
stated implied that the Obama
administration should have taken some
sort of direct action in Syria I'm
wondering what that action might have
been in the estimation of the panel what
do we go in the in the same order yeah I
think great very good questions Jim I
think you really posed two questions in
a sense where are we in the effort to
develop better prevention mechanisms and
utilizing and then what are the
prospects ones violence starts what are
the prospects behind the Security
Council and in terms of both of those i
thought the one thing that was sort of
missing from the conversation so far we
reached our Arrangements in sub regional
arrangements and i think they're
enormously important and i guess the way
we was set up no one really was
addressing what's happened regionally
but i think the African Union's
acceptance of non indifference as a
philosophy as opposed to two
non-interference was a major shift and
very important psychologically I think
the article for h and the constitutive
act of the African Union which actually
preceded the invention of the
responsibility to protect because I was
agreed in two thousand that they were in
fact as an obligation for a collective
intervention including by military force
in the case of grave circumstances and
the grave circumstances had three of the
four crimes that then were adopted by
RTP the one that wasn't there was ethnic
cleansing so I think that's quite
significant and also the equus efforts
in Liberia and the regional and global
efforts in Sierra Leone so I think in
many ways the tragic events in Rwanda
sparked a regional response that
regional response then made it much
easier for the UN to move forward and
certainly politically we never would
have gotten r2p if it wasn't for African
support and so I think that piece is
worth looking at both in terms of
prevention and when violence starts
because there have been a number of
occasions including those in echo boss
where the regional action was taken
without prior authorization from the
Security Council whatever the Charter
says so that's been interpreted fairly
liberally that you know they sort of
report to the council afterwards rather
than before that I think has been a very
important to change no I think there is
a major change and I have always argued
that r2p is basically a political
concept it has some legal niceties but
the law was already there and it is a
question about priorities it's a
question about values and the question
about standards of what we expect of
ourselves our neighbors and our
societies and the question about trying
to stop atrocity the assumption that you
should stop atrocities is relatively new
and I think largely stems from from
Rwanda so yes see
is very very frustrating as i mentioned
i spent a long time on Syria within the
UN but to the last question I don't
think there are any easy answers I think
the argument could have been made that
early on the US and others should have
one done a better job of sorting out
who's who in the opposition and to
arming and training those who were
so-called more moderate more domestic in
some ways Opposition in Syria it might
have been a positive in the end I'm not
sure that military intervention per se
would have been particularly useful in
the end and I don't think it would have
had sustainable support from the
American public but what I found and
this skins goes to sort of prevention in
a way I was actually the first making
you unofficial to say what was happening
in Syria was a crime against humanity
and then not too far after that the High
Commissioner for Human Rights said that
that didn't make much difference but if
you could have and I was didn't succeed
in persuaded those working on the
negotiations with Syria to make
protection human protection one of the
top priorities in the negotiations I
think it might have made some difference
my argument was quite frankly that one
of the things that should be emphasized
in negotiation was a need to protect
minorities in Syria including the
Alawite as a small minority and Syria
was the only case that we dealt with
directly well I thought there was a
fortunately fairly high possibility of
true genocide at the end of the day and
you know asad's claim to fame was that
he was providing protection for
minorities including obviously first and
foremost a lights but I mean we did
internal papers and and you know from
the top there's a lot of interest in
this but I must say going around two
members of the Security Council a lot of
them said yeah that was actually you
know pretty good arguments but the
Western countries didn't want it because
they said it was feeding into a solid
line that the problem was
protection of minorities and so we
politically couldn't accept that the
Russians and Chinese said well you know
sort of interesting arguments but tied
r2p and we don't really want to
emphasize that so you couldn't get any
political traction but I think that
could have changed things a little bit
in terms of the staying power of the
Assad regime and his ability to hold all
these minorities together I just wanted
to leave you one little quote from San
Francisco 1945 which I dug up somewhere
and doing research for a lecture
actually the Secretary General was
giving it oxford in 2011 and that is the
drafting committee in San Francisco 1945
in explaining the wording of article 27
which everyone sees is a great
protection for sovereignty they actually
said that if fundamental freedoms and
rights are quote previously outraged so
as to create conditions which threaten
peace or to abstract the application of
the provisions of the Charter then they
cease to be the sole concern of each
state so this is fundamental freedoms
and rights grievously outraged it ceases
to be the sole concern of each state
this is in 1945 so I don't think these
ideas of looking at sovereignty a little
more broadly are so new it's just a lot
of countries a lot of regimes a lot of
leaders found it awfully convenient to
hide behind 27 and some of these other
procedures even though that very very
strict interpretation of sovereignty
that you can do whatever you want to
population was not what actually was
intended when the charge was drafted in
1945 he fought 315 so I'm going to be
very quick I don't think it would have
made any difference in Syria what
language was put into any UN resolution
I don't think it would have made any
difference is there any women who were
among the peace negotiators I think the
only question is whether or not asad's
on calculus which was a calculus about
his own capacity to survive could have
been changed now if I had to guess I
would say whatever the United States
failed to do had it done it probably
would not have worked but there was a
decent
of chance that it might have worked that
given the consequences of doing nothing
it should have been trying my quick
definition of it would not have been
very different from what it suggested
which was certainly or significant
support for moderate rebels which would
have meant lethal aid as well as
non-lethal aid it probably would have
been money you just give these guys
money they're going to buy the guns and
ammunition someplace else they want to a
problem finding it if they have the
money should there have been an attempt
to destroy Syria's capacity to do damage
from the air I think so and I think
given what we see now about their use of
helicopters in order to draw barrel
bombs kill thousands of people the idea
that that was somehow beyond the pale of
NATO in the US Air Force I find kind of
part of that so let me stop there I'll
respond to a few of you the different
questions also what is about the
prospects for stopping atrocities today
is there any any reason to believe that
they're different than in the past
specifically in 94 I think yes in some
ways aside from the fact you know that
political well may remain challenging or
maybe the biggest stumbling block one
improvement that we do have is
technology so it's much more difficult
today for people in positions of
authority to claim that they didn't know
what was happening at the time this was
was born out I think very illustratively
in the case of the Arab Spring where and
also more recently in Syria where
members of civil society are using
social media to wonderful end to expose
atrocities I want to respond to the
question about what we knew at the time
what the US government rather knew at
the time in the case of Rwanda the US
government and I want to say this very
as clearly as I can the US government
knew that there was a genocide occurring
in Rwanda I've been researching this now
for about almost 20 years
and it seems very clear through both
declassified documents that have
obtained as well as interviews that I've
conducted with people who are deciding
who are making decisions at the time one
example is that prudence Bushnell who is
one of the senior officials in the State
Department the time was actually
speaking with some of the perpetrators
as well as some of the leaders of their
one and Patriotic Front in particular
Paul Kagame who's now the President of
Rwanda discussing what was happening in
Rwanda a min threatening them not not
threatening the the Hutu saying you know
we are watching what you're doing and
they you know the response was even were
flattered that the American government
cares please say hello to your president
does it mean that that there one in
government or the one in genocide the
genocide against the Tutsi could have
been prevented I think yes at the very
least it could have been mitigated there
were certain steps that could have been
taken to significantly mitigate the
fallout the effects of the of the
genocide proactive steps were taken to
reduce the United Nations assistance
missions the peacekeeping missions
presence the the troops are withdrawn
romeo Dallaire the commanding force the
force commander his mandate was
constricted if his mandate was expanded
if they were allowed to engage if the
troops themselves had been bolstered if
they have given more equipment then
certainly the genocide could have been
soon significantly mitigated other steps
that could have been taken some talk
about bombing the radio station or at
least jamming it that the radio in
particular was so critical to again
inciting and orchestrating the genocide
by even telling people where you know
Tootsie were hiding which ones to target
that if you had blocked that mechanism
that mechanism communication of
governmental Direction instruction that
would have helped enormously on the
point of the ICC just respond one of Jim
silks questions you know where are we
with the ICC you know certainly there
have been
improvements in the fact that we now
have a standing mechanism for both
deterrence as well as avoiding start-up
costs with the proliferation of other
mechanisms however there's lots of
reasons to still be concerned so first
of all the ICC has no enforcement
mechanism of itself it's a treaty it's
it's own court it's not part of the
United Nations although it has some
relationships and so even if it issues
arrest warrants it there's no standing
force to to you know Institute them it
relies on the goodwill of its
signatories and other partners to follow
through but arrest warrants have been
issued in the case of for example the
President of Sudan Omar al-bashir and
yet he remains at large and some believe
committing atrocities part of the
problem of course is that not all the
states have signed on and not all states
who even signed on to follow through
with their responsibilities one state of
course that hasn't signed on in the
United States government as well as
other powerful states around the world
which certainly minimizes or reduces the
ICC's effectiveness a final note okay I
final note about women in transitional
justice well it's unclear I certainly
agree with Jim it's unclear to what
extent having more women in the role in
the process of dealing with Syria would
have would have done what what more that
would have achieved it's very clear in
the case of Rwanda that women have been
absolutely critical to the recovery of
Rwanda since we're going to hear from
two individuals i greatly admire in the
next panel event and console a but
rwanda in general this is an amazing
statistic now has more women in
Parliament than any country and the
world women in many ways have led the
recovery of Rwanda and in that way you
know women really need to be
acknowledged for the role they play and
celebrated as such thanks thank you very
much for the first panel
you